[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm Cindy U the spectator's assistant
editor was the British Empire all bad
the Oxford academic and theologian Nigel
bigger says no and writes so in a new
book in so doing he was embroiled in a
culture war and was even cancelled by
his first publisher what has experience
taught him he joins me now welcome
um you write about these new
progressives now you first came into
contact with them through a project on
Empire at the University of Oxford can
you first tell us about that project
ethics and Empire yes Cindy um in July
2017 I and John Darwin the uh eminent uh
historian of of Empire worldwide uh set
up a project called ethics and Empire
and the idea of this project was over
five years through annual conferences to
to examine how people from ancient China
uh through the medieval period to the
modern period how did they view the
empires of their day um and we we held
our first conference in in July um and
then um in late November of 17 I
published an article in the London Times
in which I argued what I thought was the
anadigm position that we British can
find cause for both pride and shame in
our Imperial past um and it was just
shortly after that that I I put up a an
online description of the ethics and
Empire project and that's what got me
into
trouble um now you're a moral Theologian
by training rather than a historian per
se so was it the ethical questions that
first Drew you to the project because
Empire throughout history must be quite
Rich pickings for the complex reasons
that you say yes yes and of course the
the in the ethics Empire project we've
involved um about 55 historians
uh yes I mean it's a vast territory uh
my interest as you rightly say was in
the uh the ethical dimensions of Empire
so I I'm in the business have been in
the business professionally of uh asking
questions about good and bad right and
wrong of of complex phenomena like War
for example although my my first my
first degree was in history in my first
lover history I I read it all the
time yes and your peace and and you've
also written a book um about the British
Empire uh that's out this year that is
more focused on the British Empire so
can we you you know give give viewers a
sense of why the moral record there is
so complex you know what are the things
that you think in that you wrote um five
years ago now that you think are worth
celebrating or are worth being proud of
yes so yes my book colonialism a moral
Reckoning came out in February
um and you're quite right it focuses on
the British Empire but I I did that
because I think what is true the British
Empire is probably true of of more or
less of uh uh uh many European Empires
mon European Empires um and I I I wrote
the book because um I had come across
the the argument um first of all um put
forward by Scottish nationalists in
favor of Scottish
Independence that um Britain equals
Empire equals
evil and therefore for Scotland to
become independent would be an act of
national self-purification
and I've been reading
about uh British imperial history for um
30 years or so and I
knew that uh you cannot say of the
British
Empire that was equivalent to evil
uh partly because
um for example yes it's true uh that in
the 150 years from 1650 to the early
1800s uh some British have been involved
in slave trading and
slavery but it's also true that from
1807 uh and 1833 respectively the
British were among the first people in
the history of the world to abolish both
slave trading and slavery so you can't
talk about colonialism and slavery as if
they were the same thing uh and then
just to pick some other uh another
example um if you uh happen to find
yourself uh driving around the Southwest
slopes of Mount etler in Sicily in Italy
uh driving uh um eastwards toward rbo on
the left hand side uh you will come
across a World War II Cemetery full of
young Canadians and if you wander around
the headstones you'll come across one
headstone uh that belongs to HR Anderson
who was killed in July 1943 at the age
of 28 and Thea describes him as an
anti-fascist fighter and he was a
volunteer answering the call to fight
Nazism and it was the British Empire
that called him so uh if if you're
against fascism uh then you need to
credit the British Empire for uh between
19 May 1940 and June 41 providing the
only military opposition to Nazi Germany
with the sole exception of Greece so
there are some things to be said in
favor of the British
Empire empire but what about the
day-to-day then the because you know
these are two good examples of of big
topics that big things that Empire has
um been against but what about the
day-to-day you know the LI lives of the
colonized and the IND indigenous um I
guess it brings to mind that Monte
python you know what have the Romans
ever done for us yeah um so
um I mean in my book I'm perfectly clear
that that uh the Empire presided over
bad things as well as good uh so if you
ask about the day-to-day effect then on
on North Americans in the 1600s 1700s
and on Australian aboriginals in the
1800s I'm afraid one of the major
effects on on these people's was was
disease because Europeans brought um
small pox to these parts of the world
Europeans wen't the only ones doing it I
mean um Indonesians may have brought
small pox to Northern Australia and if
Europeans took small pox to North
America they also brought back syphilis
to Europe uh no one planned to do it it
it was uh devastating it was tragic
lamentable but uh you can't blame
Europeans for doing that it was entirely
accidental that was one negative impact
but positive impact would be um the the
imposition of Imperial Authority uh
meant the suppression of
endemic uh uh Warfare between different
peoples in Africa or um Australia um or
or toia uh so so the empire did have the
Merit of imposing peace and if you don't
have peace you can't flourish
economically um the the East India
Company helped to impose peace on uh
Northern India in the late 1700s and uh
there were testimonies to the um
immediately positive economic effects
has had um um and you know I could I
could mention the the introduction of um
tropical medicine that uh for the first
time uh relieved people of uh um um um
sickness through through suffering
various tropical diseases so I mean the
the Empire the European Empire the
British Empire uh brought the benefits
of modernity modern technology modern
medicine modern science to
parts of the world that in terms of of
scientific and technological development
were um um relatively
underdeveloped um I could go on but
there there a mixture of the there are
mixtures of of goods and evils and I in
the conclusion I I I give a long list of
the bad stuff and a long list of the
good
things and that moral calculus is quite
interesting isn't it no I wonder if from
an ethical perspective you you risk
ending up in a bit of a utility Arian
perspective where you think that the
ends are somehow worth talking about you
know in terms of the means when you talk
about things like economic flourishment
for example just to be you know Devil's
Advocate on this that is the argument
that the Chinese Communist Party uses to
justify its rule of China and has done
in the last uh 30 years since economic
reforms so where do you draw the line
there then because sure the colonized
had better roads and better economies
perhaps but they were still colonized
against their
will well um it's not I mean it wasn't
always the case it's too simple to say
they were colonized against against
their will um in some cases they were
the truth is in most parts of the world
uh the lower classes The Peasants that
they they were used to being ruled by
people that uh ruled them whether it
doesn't matter whether they were in
India whether they're Muslim mugal or
Hindus or Brits or French most people in
the world were not in control of lives
they were always rul by someone else the
Brits were just just the latest but it's
not true to say that natives were always
ruled against their will I mean just you
mentioned China so why was it that um
that um no one knows how many millions
of Chinese people volun terally left the
Chinese Mainland and entered Hong Kong
in the late 1950s and 60s because of
Civil War and because of Communism on
Mainland China now Hong Kong was not a
democracy but it provided the rule of
law and it it provided stable
institutions and people were able to
build uh compared to what was available
to them on the Chinese Mainland able to
build decent lives and a stable
environment and that's so so um
Democratic choice is good but I think
actually in terms of the lives of people
a certain stability that allows you to
build a life uh uh secure from from
external threats uh is probably more
basic to political good to political
good now Nigel as I talked to you I can
see why you have had negative experience
is with these new progressives can't
imagine well what you're advocating for
is very nuanced and I think Empires a
very emotive topic as you know were you
surprised at the reaction to your
project and to your
book well uh back in 2017 I was shocked
um because for two reasons one is um the
the ethics and Empire
project uh was not about defending
Empire I suppose it did make the
assumption it did State the Assumption
in the uh in the online description that
that we we didn't we don't assume that
Empire is always
Wicked uh that sometimes it can be
legitimate so I think that was probably
in the eyes of some that was our
cardinal sin um um but one of the things
we discovered early on in in the project
was that uh if if you want to
find as it were critiques of empire in
ancient China or uh uh in the medieval
Arab world
you won't find them they don't exist you
will find uh discussions of what makes
for a good and bad Emperor but but
Empire as a political form was taken
entirely for granted an Empire has been
a common form all over the world
practiced by people of every skin color
until the the modern period um so so the
ethic project was a genuine academic
project um uh it wasn't say it wasn't
all saying that Empire is always to be
defended and praised um and then when I
published that article in the London
Times in November again I thought um you
know who who can possibly say that that
um British Empire doesn't contain good
things as well as bad I've mentioned
some of the good things I mean you may
decide in the end that it was more bad
than good although I'm not a you to the
Teran I I don't think you can do that I
could talk more about how I go on to
make a moral judgment but you can do
that but but you can't I don't think you
can deny that the British Empire had did
some good things um but I discovered
that um uh the the Assumption of the
ethics Empire project uh namely that
Empire could be legitimate and my
argument that British canate good things
that clearly was unacceptable to uh a
group of of academics and historians who
uh um um subjected me and the project to
a uh a a a series of online
denunciations in the space of a week in
December 17 yes and off the back of that
you got a book contract from Bloomsbury
publishing to publish an intelligent
Person's Guide to colonialism now there
was a whole Saga over that book because
you wrote it but Bloomsbury then dropped
it uh and what you heard was that it was
pressure from younger members of Staff
although Bloomsbury is I think it's
worth saying say that books are dropped
for all sorts of reasons but I was
pleased to say see that it was picked up
by William Collins and actually was
published at this year now you recently
had a piece in The Spectator looking at
the people who sought to tarnish your
name back in 2017 and also over this
book you call them the new progressives
so what do you think motivates these
people well you should shall I just
explain a bit as to to why the question
arises yeah it's it goes back it goes
back to to um the rules was full utation
in Oxford in 2015 16 uh when when uh
students were clambering for the
dismantling of a rather obscure statue
of the late Victorian imperialist Cil
roads who died in
02 uh and and I was um I I was aware of
this and I fact I
was two-thirds of the way through a very
fat biography of roads by Robert
rockberg at the time and uh one one
thing I noticed was the claims been made
that road was South Africa's hler and
that he committed
genocide uh which is not true
historically so one thing I observed was
whatever is moting these guys to clamor
for Ro's downfall is not
history um um and then secondly I
noticed
um at the time when they were um
protesting in Oxford and and the the
leader of the campaign was a young South
African Road scholar uh cheerfully
biting the hand that was feeding him
um and um he was from South Africa as I
say meanwhile in South Africa Jacob Zuma
was looting the South African State
bringing South Africa to the verge of
insolvency and exposing its people to
destitution and I noticed that here are
all these rather privileged Oxford
postgraduates on scholarships to come
study at Oxford uh clamoring for the
downfall of a long forgotten long Dead
uh um Bri imperialist while South Africa
is burning and about South Africa they
have nothing to say so that that's what
rais the question so what's really going
on here um um and and I I I just read
recently and I mentioned this in my
article a book by rakib isan who's a I
think a Pakistani born Pakistani
Heritage uh Britain his book's called
Beyond grievance what the left get wrong
gets wrong about uh
um ethnic minorities and he makes the
same observation about um leering
anti-racist groups that uh the evidence
is that that in Britain we don't have um
ethnic minorities in the one hand being
oppressed and disadvantaged by white
people in the other it's far more
complicated uh some some ethnic
minorities Asians do extremely well do
do far better than than white Britains
uh uh West African Britains do better
than Caribbean Britains and they all do
better than poor
whites uh so it's much more complicated
and and he said uh
nevertheless um and he's talking to the
labor party of which is a member I think
certainly votes for it he says
nevertheless labor and anti-racism
groups uh uh remain wited to pedling a
radical American origin uh uh racial
politics According to which Britain is
systematically racist and it's all
because of white prejudice
uh so so again the the discrepancy
between as it were the the real causes
of inequalities between ethnic groups
and um the the protests raising the
question is what's really going on here
because you know if you really care
about injustices between uh different
groups in society then then above all
else you want to understand what are the
causes of it because unless you
understand the causes you can't remedy
it um uh but it seems the many people on
the left committed to anti-racism don't
want to hear any diagnosis other than
simple racial Prejudice on the part of
whites so it's what you think motivates
them as a victimhood narrative I mean
it's interesting in your article you
also spot a certain kind of Christian
sensibility but one that's rather
corrupted yeah yeah so yes you asked you
know what are what what does motivate uh
these uh in this case these Progressive
anti-racists and and I'm not you know no
doubt there are people in there
sincerely believe what they're saying
but it is odd that they're not curious
to know you know if there is evidence
that prejudice is not the cause if there
is evidence then if they really cared
they would be curious about it and
they're not um so what's motivating well
asan himself suggests money that uh um
anti-racist groups depend for funding on
the being a problem so it doesn't serve
the interests if the problem goes away
or if the problem is not what they say
it is so partly money that I added the
fact that of course
um um there are plenty of people who
have built their careers the political
careers on anti-racism and they've made
all sorts of friends and allies on that
basis and it would be quite costly in
terms of career for them to start
backtracking um and you've also got a
very burgeoning diversity industry these
days going into major corporations to
train people on their unconscious bias
of course yes you're quite right so
there's that too so as as it where the
the business has expanded and and to to
to to start saying things are more
complicated means uh it's a threat to
business so ironically I I mean people
on the right can behave this way too uh
let's be clear about that but ironically
for the left uh um uh there may be an
element of of commercial interest here
that is at stake um so there was that
but I still think there's something
deeper uh and I mentioned this in the
epilogue to my book uh I I just find it
odd that people
um believe the worst of their own
country when the evidence says they
don't have to right so if it were true
that Britain was systemically racist and
that our Colonial history was a Litany
of racism and oppression and and
violence and warranted violence then as
a Britain I should accept that because
it's true but the evidence is that is
not so why do people continue to believe
it's true when it's not and indeed why
do they they behave why do they react to
people like me who say here's the
evidence not true why do they react not
with curiosity not
skepticism but with aggression so as I
mentioned uh um in December 17 um lots
of academics got together to try and
shut down my project on ethics and
Empire which wasn't an invitation to
discussion it was a repression why
behave that way um well one explanation
which I think is plausible and I got
this really from Pascal Brooker the uh
French Jesuit educ educated
philosopher it's a kind of degenerate
Christianity so um uh Christians believe
that that um um truly saintly virtuous
people are people who are deeply aware
of just how un virtuous they are there's
a kind of paradox there this you're
deeply aware of you and sinfulness and
flaws which makes you ironically
paradoxically more
holy that's that's a good thing in many
respects but um it can be perverted so
uh uh the thesis is that um some people
nowadays think that um um if I can
declare myself or my culture or my
nation to be uniquely
sinful it's it's it's a it's a kind of
perverse way of retaining the moral High
ground and Brookner says this is what
Europe's doing Europe is no longer a
superpower doesn't grow the world
anymore but it tries to be a moral
superpower by saying we are the worst
oppressors ever in the history of the
world and no one did it as bad as we did
um so it's a kind it's a kind of virtue
signaling that makes us feel us feel
more righteous because we are more
self-critical than anybody doesn't
matter about the evidence now what's
what's significant about that is this is
not about the disadvantaged it's not
about the poor and the oppressed it's
about the Crusader it's about the
anti-racist Crusader it's about the
decolonizing Crusader it's not really
about them it's about us and um that I
think uh is is
plausible and finally n because we're
rapidly running out of time but do you
have hope for the future when it comes
to discourse in this culture do do you
are you optimistic about where we might
go from here yeah certainly I am I know
I know there are colleagues of mine who
are very dismal about it but no I am
because um a lot has happened in the
last four years in this country um
um since I first got into trouble six
years
ago
um um we've had the foundation of the
Free Speech Union in early 2020 which
does great work in holding institutions
to account and embarrassing uh colleges
and sometimes even Publishers um in
terms of thep suppression of lawful free
speech um also we've had the
government's legislation on um high
education freed with speech will do it
will be be very effective once ARF akmed
the new director of freedom speech gets
up and running um in um in supporting
academics and students to speak their
minds within the law on race or gender
or
colonialism and um um on on on the race
issue not only did we have the
government's um cred report the ter Fel
report in
2021 uh I mean since then we have raki
asan's book this year we had before that
to oadi is also very good book this is
not America uh why black lives matter in
Britain which both um asan and and oadi
really confirm the credit reports claims
about this is not black versus white
it's far more complicated and sometimes
it is of bage is not the result of
prejudice so there are other causes too
that's good and then the fact is my book
got published it has sold twice as many
copies twice as many copies as as my BL
predicted um and I noticed another a
number of other books pushing back
against the radical uh decolonizing
anti-colonialist Trend so um there's
still a lot a lot a lot more to be
fought uh but I'm I'm not discouraged um
and um I think we can we can achieve
more balance uh in in years to come
Nigel bigger thank you for ending on a
note of Hope thank you very much for
joining need the
[Music]
shame